this is a defeat i mean i think there
should be accountability and if you and
this could be a kind of opening for a
kind of bipartisan conversation because
if you are
a kind of um
american militarist
i mean you have to look at the
leadership that got you to a place where
you're defeated by
men wearing sandals
firing ak-47s right yeah there should be
a humility with that yeah
i mean yeah we should actually say that
we like literally
the oh we lost you seriously lost it
wasn't just you know um
the the american military
lost yeah and i i feel i have very mixed
feelings and you know it's
i don't know a ton of veterans but you
know i've mentioned i've taught my share
and
have a student now and
you know they are
they're suffering because they look at
the sacrifices that they made that i
didn't make i mean american society did
make the sacrifices i mean
men and women lost limbs they lost eyes
they lost lives you know
there's been this of course quiet
epidemic of suicide
among
among veterans and i
i've heard
some stories the fact that the state
department is seeing a similar surge of
suicides because
they see their
adult life's work
collapse they've seen their
relationships i mean they've seen they
were seeing phone calls in the middle of
night from people who they entrusted
with their lives
who they know are going to be targeted i
mean some have already been killed um
they've seen the i mean i think just i'd
imagine just ideologically and
professionally
what they believed in and what they
what they sacrificed for
has vanished
and i think that's a that's
that's bad i mean historically thinking
of some of the presence you were
thinking of i mean if you think of
you know first of all you know at a
human level i feel horrible for those
people who you know may not have agreed
with
everything they've done and their
choices in life but i respect the fact
that many good people went out of
you know the best intentions as young
people to to to do the right thing and
make things right and i respect that
and i've met enough to know that
there were people who
saw the gray and complexity and that
that's
you know all you can hope for um
but we don't want a generation of
disillusioned veterans um
you know if we look at the
other post-war moments and this is kind
of a possible moment where
you know i think we need a conversation
with american veterans about about what
they've gone through and what they're
feeling and they have they solve skin in
the game you know because their personal
connections and their in the end of
their histories and also going to be
future leaders i mean uh
veterans already yeah people who have
served are
often great men and women that's that's
true and
you know throughout history whether you
sacrifice you served in fighting world
war ii
in fighting vietnam that's going to mold
you in different ways
that's going to mold
how you are as the leader that leads
this country forward and uh so you have
to have an honest conversation about um
what was um
the role of the war in afghanistan the
war in the middle east the war on terror
in the history of america if we just
look at the full context at the end of
this 21st century how we're going to
remember this
and how that's going to result
in our future interactions with small
and large countries with china or some
proxy war with china with russia or some
proxy war with uh
russia what's the role of oil and
natural resources and opium and all
those kinds of things what's the role of
military power
uh in the world and now with kovid
you know it it's like um
it's almost like
the
because of the
many failures of the us government
and many leaders
uh in in science and politics to respond
effectively and quickly
to uh to covid we kind of forget that we
fumbled this other thing too yeah and
it's it's hard to know which is going to
be more expensive yeah uh
they seem to be symptoms of something
of us of a same kind of source
problem um
of leadership of bureaucracy of of uh
the way information and intelligence
flows throughout the u.s government all
those kinds of things and that hopefully
motivates young leaders to fix things
you